it's hard going for the fire crews in
the mountains of galicia in northwestern
spain
wildfires are popping up everywhere
we find a team that's scrambling to stop
this one moving any closer to the
village just below
it just sparked alba fernandez tells me
it crossed on the wind from a different
fire and reached over here
these blazes are burning quickly through
the drought parched forest worrying for
the firefighters who live in the places
they are trying to protect
we're being moved
okay as the flames push us back
volunteer carlos prada explains one of
the central challenges of tackling fires
here
the real problem he says is there's no
place to put the firefighting machinery
that's the real problem
the terrain is utterly unforgiving some
fires can't even be reached
it's a huge effort just to move up and
down the rocky slopes
they're using diggers to push
brush and plants and dry twigs and logs
out of the way to try and create a fire
break
the firefighters have let us come up the
hill to watch them finish up they've
just put out a fire just to see how
dangerous it is how hot and dry it is
and how once they put out one set of
flames another lot pops up
district fire chief lorena fernandez
knows that if communities want to remain
here things have to change
the administration has to invest she
says the forests have to be more
carefully managed and the land kept
clear around these mountains
but in the nearby province of zamora
where the blackened forests run for
miles another fire chief is
contemplating a different problem
do you think fire season is getting
worse as climate change makes the planet
hotter of course there's no doubt about
that i have been working for 22 years
and we have never been seen that
condition on the fire never it's
completely new for us
tens of thousands of acres burned
thousands of people evacuated
deaths injuries and the fires are still
burning
this nation paying a high price as our
world heats up
hannah thomas peter sky news in galethia
in spain